a few years ago all the developed
countries in the world the wealthier
ones and all of the charities together
donated about two hundred billion
dollars to developing countries in the
world the ones that bear most of the
burden the heaviest burden of the
world's biggest problems poverty hunger
climate change and inequality that same
year business is invested in those same
countries three point seven trillion
dollars now I get to travel a lot in my
work and I'm privileged to see the
amazing things that NGOs and some
governments are doing with some of that
200 billion dollars helping malnourished
children or families that don't have
access to clean water children who
wouldn't be educated otherwise but it's
not enough because the biggest problems
in our world need trillions not just
billions so if we're gonna make lasting
and significant progress and the big
challenges in our world we need business
both the companies and the investors to
drive the solutions so let's talk about
what business should do and when I say
that you probably think that I'm gonna
talk about corporate philanthropy or
corporate social responsibility CSR is
the norm today and it's very useful it
provides a route for corporate
generosity and that generosity is
important to many corporations employees
and customers but you know what it's
just not big enough or strong enough or
durable enough to drive solutions to the
biggest problems in our world today
because it's incremental cost even when
business is booming CSR just isn't
designed to scale and then of course in
a downturn it's one of the first
grams to be cut so no CSR corporate
social responsibility isn't the answer
but TSI total societal impact is TSI is
the sum of all of the ways business can
affect society by doing their real work
thinking about their supply chains
working on their product design and
manufacturing processes and their
distribution the real work of business
when done with innovation can actually
create core business benefits for the
company and it can solve the meaningful
problems in our world today so what is
TSI look like focusing on TSI means
incorporating social and environmental
considerations and you know what it's
something that isn't completely new it's
been thought about for a while but the
hard part is that corporations almost
exclusively still think about something
called PS our total shareholder returns
but TSI total societal impact needs to
stand alongside TSR as an important and
valid driver of corporate strategy and
corporate decision-making and we've got
the data to show you why and how and
some companies are already making this
happen they're beginning to make it
happen so let me tell you the story
about Mars Mars is the sixth largest
private company in the United States if
you're like me they make some important
products like coffee and chocolate so
not surprisingly one of their most
important gradients is cocoa and some of
their competitors are actually really
worried about the sustainability and the
availability of cocoa supplies
but not Mars they're confident in the
stable supply of that Prop for the long
term and why is that it's because they
partner with NGOs around the world that
are working with small shareholder
farmers and those certification agencies
NGOs are working to help farmers improve
crop yields they're making sure that
they get a fair premium livable wage and
they're helping them address any human
rights potential issues and supply
chains and they're helping minimize the
effects on the environment like
deforestation Mars is in a path to 100
percent certified cocoa so this is a
good program for farming communities
it's a good program for the environment
and it's a good program for Mars who has
solved a significant risk in their
supply chain but now let's get to the
data because it's actually really
awesome and let me explain exactly what
the data points I'm going to talk about
our when analysts and financial people
look at companies they think about a lot
of different statistics I want to talk
about two of the most important ones you
know talk about the overall value of a
company its valuation and I'm going to
talk about its margin basically the
difference between all of its earnings
and all of its costs so in our study we
looked at oil and gas companies and the
oil and gas companies that are
performing most strongly on TSI total
societal impact see a 19% premium and
their valuation 19% when they do really
well on things like minimizing the
impact of their company on the
environment and water and when they do
very strong occupational health and
safety programs and when they also add
in strong employee training programs
they get a three point four percentage
point premium on their margins but what
about other industries
biopharmaceutical companies that are the
strongest performers on TSI see a 12
percent premium on their valuation and
then if their best on expanded access to
medicines making medicines available for
the people who need them they see a six
point seven percentage point premium on
their gross margins for the retail banks
that are strongest on TSI they see a
three percentage point premium on their
valuation and then for those that
differentially provide Financial
Inclusion access to financial products
for people who need it they see a 0.5
percentage point premium in their net
income margin now these numbers for
banks may not seem very big but in
highly competitive industries even
really small differences in margin
matter a lot now what about those
consumer goods companies the one who
make those products we love like coffee
and chocolate consumer goods companies
that perform best on total societal
impact see an 11 percent valuation
premium and then if they do those smart
things with their supply chain inclusive
and responsibly sourcing their product
they see a four point eight percentage
point premium on their gross margins
these numbers are significant we've long
known that things like fundamental
financials growth rates and financial
risks are key drivers of valuation but
this rigorous analysis shows that social
and environmental factors total societal
impact measures are also linked to
valuations and margins Wow
all else equal we didn't confuse the
analysis with anything all those being
equal companies that perform strongly on
social and environmental areas achieve
higher margins and higher valuations now
I do understand
companies are under a lot of short-term
earnings pressures but fortunately the
investors who create some of this
pressure are actually more and more
themselves starting to think longer term
and starting to think with this TSI lens
in our conversations and surveys with
investors 75% of them say they expect to
see improved revenues and improved
operating efficiency for companies that
are thinking with the TSI lens and
they're actually starting to incorporate
this in their own investing behavior
last year twenty three trillion in
global assets were in the category of
socially responsible investing now
that's a five billion over just the last
two years and it represents a quarter of
the total global assets managed in the
world I know that some of you may be
cringing a little bit right now because
in my decades of strategy consulting
with businesses and NGOs and governments
around the world I find that many
business people are hesitant to talk or
even sometimes think about the business
benefits of doing good they somehow
think it's gonna engage the value of the
benefits they're creating for society or
that they'll be perceived as heartless
or even mercenary but we really do need
to think differently we need to think
differently because the only way we're
going to make substantial progress on
the challenging problems of our time is
for business to drive the solutions the
job of business is to meet customer
needs and to do so profitably they need
to to survive so one of the best ways
for businesses to help ensure their own
growth their own longevity is to meet
some of the hard
challenges in our society and to do so
profitably and when they do that
innovatively
when they do that ethically responsibly
incredibly they should be proud but if
you still aren't sure about this let's
talk about a few more examples what if
you're a technology company and you're
trying to grow your platform and you're
trying to grow your customers like
Airbnb Airbnb has a portfolio of total
societal impact activities they're all
spot on their core business in one
initiative they're helping enable their
community to provide housing for free to
those in disaster crisis survivors and
relief workers in another idea in
another effort on their part they're
actually helping and working with NGOs
to ensure that people can provide
housing for free for Refugees now what I
love about this program is that I don't
think most people would have figured out
how to express their generosity and open
their homes for those in such dire need
certainly not so quickly or so easily or
efficiently without this innovation by
Airbnb but at the same time this is core
to their corporate strategy and core to
their growth because they grow by
increasing the number of hosts and
guests using their platform but if
they'd only been thinking exclusively
about the return side of things I'm not
sure they would have ever figured out
this route to growth because they're not
charging transaction fees so it's a
pretty exciting way when they were
thinking about how to bring their
capabilities to a need in society and at
the same time drive their own growth but
what if you're trying to find new
customer segments let's move to South
Africa and let's talk about standard
bank in South Africa the government has
a regulation that requires all bang
to donate 0.2% of their profits to small
and medium black owned enterprises and
many banks just donate this to the
entrepreneurs but standard bank thought
creatively and what they did is they
took those funds and they invested them
in an independent trust and they use
that trust to fund loans to these black
entrepreneurs this is a highly leveraged
model they can support a lot more
entrepreneurs with capital and because
their success is completely intertwined
with the success of the entrepreneurs
they're actually also using the fund to
provide technical assistance more
entrepreneur supported more people and
communities being lifted out of poverty
and it's successful for standard Bank so
successful that they're actually working
on expanding this program to other areas
in their portfolio it's not like we
haven't been trying to solve the
problems in our world for a long time we
have and they're still here we're making
progress but it's not far enough or fast
enough or universal enough we need to
flip our thinking we need to have
business both companies and investors
bring creative innovative corporate
strategy and capital to solving the
biggest problems in our world and when
they do that innovatively and when they
do that with all of their thinking and
all of their strategy and all of their
capital and they're creating both total
shareholder returns and total societal
impact we know that we will solve those
problems both profitably and generously
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]